Santa Claus doesn't have to wake up and
read that Matthew Perry died from a
ketamine overdose in his hot
tub Santa doesn't have to read that with
Miss Claus while they have breakfast
they have
um I don't know what they'd eat for
breakfast a porridge or a an oatmeal but
Santa doesn't have to say ho ho ho get
me some oatmeal how did Matthew par
die oh it was ketamine overdose in his
hot tub Miss
Claus and then Miss Claus goes well a
lot of the elves have been going for
that ketamine
therapy to kind of relive their past
traumas and try to get to the other side
of them and he goes well I will that
just seems like they're using
drugs Matthew Perry died in his hot tub
from
ketamine and Santa doesn't have to live
it cuz he's he's
gone there is no Santa Claus and if
there was he'd be a gas at what's going
on right
now he would have assumed much like I
did that because Matthew pered had a
drug addiction for a very long time and
it ate away a lot of his liver I think
he was doing like 46 Viking in a
day that's what I thought it was I just
thought it was just one of those
things unfortunately it's not one of
those things it was a ketamine overdose
in his hot
tub which sucks well vicadin he was
using vicadin he was taking up to
55 vikin in a
day and that does a number on your
liver that's what I thought it was but
it was an overdose of
ketamine ketamine is the new it drug in
Hollywood like
OIC OIC is the shot you take to make you
less
fat ketamine is something
else it's a drug which I used to do when
I was doing drugs we called It Special K
we did it with ecstasy which is now
called
Molly but it's a drug that is supposed
to realign the Pathways in your brain
and everyone here is always doing that
they're always realigning the Pathways
in their brain they're taking
iasa they're on ketamine all the time
this is everyone in
La that you speak to they go I have to
realign my
neural Pathways because reality is too
Bleak that's really what it comes they
go I
can't deal with the reality of what's
going on I need my
brain this is going to be tough the
beard breathing in
hair it's hard to breathe with the beard
on because I have a Santa beard on how
did I you know I used to do this you
know I was a I was a Santa who tried to
sign people up for Obamacare no way
years ago this is
true I was a
Santa little breath
my [__] God I have this cold sore
that's also why this kind of is nice to
have I was a Santa who signed people up
for Obamacare I would go into bad
neighborhoods and I would sign uh poor
low-income people up for
Obamacare dressed as Santa Claus and it
was a job that I did and it was a job
that I did to supplement uh the money
while I was earning uh money to learn
how to be a stand-up
comedian and it was not a bad gig was
not a great gig because you would be in
bad areas and poor people are very
depressing around the
holidays it's true they they're always
getting getting shot or what I mean
they're just they're depressing people
over the holidays holidays are really
for you know it's really it's better to
have rich people or Rich family and
friends over the holidays because they
you
know holidays are for them you know like
the the poor people are always getting
shot or sick or they're working shifts
and they're complaining all the time and
that's not you know it's neither here
nor there but that's why the job was
tough because they would always say you
know rich people around the holidays
they're just wearing coats and going to
church and having these feasts so when I
was at Santa in a poor neighborhood and
I was poor and everybody I'm talking to
is poor nobody's happy we're all
broke they're asking me questions about
healthc care I didn't sign up for Obama
I don't know I don't know what's going
on I'm just sitting in a truck dressed
to
Santa and they're they're telling me
about problems that they have I have
problem it wasn't it wasn't a good time
in my
life but I can't even remember I'm like
how did I [__] do this with the beard
it's terrible it really irritates you at
one time and I told I talked about this
on the Pod there was I did it at a
Spanish chicken
restaurant I don't know what I where it
was it was on Long Island and there was
a big chicken and Santa mhm they had a
big chicken and everybody wanted photos
with me nobody wanted photos with the
chicken the chicken was dressed like a
chicken he was very upset about that he
was also signing up PE people for
ObamaCare what what the government
did to
get no but it's all true what the
government did to get lowincome people
on into Obamacare was they sent out like
like characters whether it was like me a
Santa or a chicken or like the Kool-Aid
guy they sent him out into the streets
I'm not even kidding you can look this
up and it's probably not a bad idea they
sent like characters out into the they
sent out like
SpongeBob to try to get people to sign
up for ObamaCare because you know people
don't like doctors right they get
creeped out by doctors they're creeped
out by people that are wearing suits but
like if Clifford the Big Red Dog or
SpongeBob or you know I don't know Paw
Patrol goes out and goes hey do you want
uh health insurance you might you might
be more amenable to
it I don't
know but there were that was like a
strategy that they had back to Matthew
Perry I gotta I gotta take this beard
off I I it's the cold s is not that bad
it's it's I I can't deal with this
hurting my face to a point where I I
can't even you know I can't even deal
with
it Matthew Perry rip very sad um we
don't we obviously do not uh we're not
making light of his
death you know but what here's what we
saying about this ketam me because
everybody's doing this
now and I you know as somebody who is a
ex addict I think maybe it's not a good
idea maybe it's not a good idea but
maybe it is I don't know but a lot of
people are are are taking ketamine under
the supervision of a doctor they're
going to a clinic and I don't know I
guess this can help with PTSD
yeah you know for people that have come
back from
war but it seems to be abused people
seem to be abusing it like I know a lot
of people who do it and I go the last
thing you need to do is go and get shot
up with ketamine in a clinic you need
something else you don't need to do
ketamine in a
clinic that's not what is for iasa is
not for you having a better
career that's not what it's for that's
not what the Incans intended that's not
what the Mayans whoever the f I don't
even care or
no the ancient cultures that used iasa
as a spiritual experience were not
intending it to be used so that you
could figure out how to get on Netflix
there's no way there's no possible way
that's the intention of
iasa there's no way there's no way that
you were supposed to go into hypers
space and ask the the aliens the
entities or for career advice there's no
way it's it's it's all
been completely
perverted by people that are in this
town
want to just figure out how to make life
more about
themselves as if it's not already about
them they want to do they want to make
it more about themselves
somehow somehow some way they go enough
of life isn't about
me let me
really focus let me take three days let
me go to Peru let me
vomit and let me realize that all my
fears are just they're not real they're
holding me back and listen again this
would be great if the end goal wasn't to
you know snag a rooll on jinny and
Georgia like if you were really evolving
as a human
being you would leave you would move you
would leave if iasco worked you'd come
back to LA walk into your house burn it
down light it on fire and leave the
state forever if iasa were but whatever
professional grade Iowa and I don't know
who these shamans are these con
artists that are calling themselves
shamans people are drinking this stuff
all every three weeks they're on iasa
and they're more [__] than they've
ever been on
iasa I don't get
it and now people are dropping dead in
their hot tubs of ketamine everyone's
like no it's good it's the rewires
neural Pathways in the brain and because
it's a lot to take it's a lot to take
when all of the big studios go we want a
a future uh without humans we want a
posthuman future it's a lot to take
people go [__] I gotta take Samaya to
handle that I gotta take a little ketam
to handle that so that's what the
studios did they just said hey I talked
to some of these people during this
strike and they were very clear about
what they want they want a a postum
future on Earth that's all they want
they're very clear about it they want a
post human future on
Earth that's what they want that's what
they want they don't want human beings
anymore and that's tough to hear because
everybody's having the wrong fight
everybody's like you're paying me $30 I
want 35 it's like no no no no no no no
we don't want you to exist we want you
God we want you out we want to do things
completely AI generated we don't want
you at all it's hard to hear it's hard
to hear that's where everybody's got to
go take iasa they got to do ketamine one
of these writers a guy The Hollywood
Reporter
went to do ketamine and flipped
out which is a kind It's Kind of a Funny
article when ketamine therapy visit goes
horribly wrong
so what this guy did and this guy sounds
kind of like a [__] who can't handle
his drugs now that doesn't mean that
this ketamine fad is good I know a lot
of people that are doing
this ain't not a one of them in a in a
place mentally that you should be ain't
not a one not a one of those people
walking around doing ketamine that I
know and the tens of dozens of people I
know doing ketamine are are in good uh
place all the
time I sought help from aamine Clinic
like Matthew Perry odd way to start it's
an interesting way to start the article
huh I sought help from a ketamine Clinic
like Matthew Perry things went wrong
what happened was the scariest
experience of my life here's what
happened the guy goes in the
room you know listen to this I was
probably always going to get around to
to Tran ketamine therapy which I did two
years
ago I had read all the things how the
animal tranquilizer and party drug can
work wonders for treatment resistant
depression how it can reset your brain
there it is again H ketamine's unique
disassociative effect allows the user to
take a step back get off their hamster
wheel of ego-driven thinking by the way
everyone I know on this stuff
it's it they're the they're the most
egomaniacal people I've ever met in my
life all of the people on this by the
way without exception it's completely
about their all the time about them
everybody I know who does this stuff
never starts a sentence with any other
except I all of them so I love this
idea that is that it's you we're trying
to get rid of your ego with this in in
La that's what we're trying to get rid
of rid of the ego is that why these
people were doing all of this CU their
ego they want to get rid of their ego no
they they want to help themselves get
more things
somehow they think this leads to them
getting more famous that's why they're
doing it because they want to get out of
their own way because people keep
telling them hey man everyone hates you
you come to the Christmas party drunk
you try to [__] someone's wife you're
not focused you suck and that's why
you're not succeeding you should do
ketamine and figure out why you act like
an [__] all the time so that's the
group of people that are doing this the
people are like yeah can you do ketamine
and stop trying to [__] my wife all the
time you
scumbag and they go I got to reset my
brain because everyone's telling them to
everyone's telling me I got to reset my
brain I have to stop doing coke and
trying to rape children in La so they go
I'm I'm going to go get ketamine
treatment so listen I showed up from my
appointment filled out forms signed a
waiver and was ushered to a small dim
room with blinds on the
windows the room Center P centerpiece
was a cushy faux leather recliner that
faced an LED TV that was mounted high on
the wall next to the chair was an IV
stand the technician was a young woman
let's call her
Sarah it was unclear if she had any
medical credential credentials I'll stop
you there buddy she didn't
probably but she had this I'm just going
through the motion so do you want to
order any appetizers casualness made me
think not so she's basically the
ketamine waitress and so she gives him
ketamine and he goes I felt confused why
was I here again I started to feel like
I wasn't entirely in the room or was I
in the room and then I wasn't did you
give me the drug already so he flips out
he has a bad uh trip if if you want to
call it that he's uh doesn't know what's
going on it's unfortunate he gets uh
paranoid the room was gone I was gone
typically when you take a drug you
experience reality differently you feel
good or bad and what you're seeing might
not be accurate but you were still you
you know this was different I was
unconscious technically but in a void
it's a khole it's khole I've been in a
khole I was 14 you're in a cake you're
doing drugs what's wrong with these
people you're doing D drugs these crazy
people people are taking katom now like
you you put heroin in a smoothie it's
heroin still you're doing drugs they I I
don't understand what these people
think's going to happen because a nurse
gives it to you they killed Michael
Jackson they kill all of these people
they will give you anything you want if
you have the money they'll give you
anything you want they don't know if you
need this therapy or not they don't
care you're doing drugs and listen I'm
not a moralist in this regard I don't
think you should hurt other people but
if you get you know something out of
this positively great but it's a
drug people get to all kinds of Altered
States Of Consciousness all kinds of
ways fasting uh meditation all kinds of
other ways this is a shortcut you're
you're pulling up in a valley in strip
mall you're sitting down you're getting
an IV while you're in a lazy boy that's
a shortcut to the Altered States of
reality you're trying to get to it's a
drug all these people are like I had no
idea what's going on I just sat down and
they shot me up with a drug and then I
was high what's
that this was such a disassociative
state that I was disassociated from
everything that I ever knew existed I
was in space but not outer space What
horrible by the way what horrible
writing what terrible writing
I was in space but not outer space
nothing so neatly familiar as that there
were colors jungle greens and Browns
well that's what he doesn't like the
Browns jungle greens and Browns hey
watch out buddy I think the Drug's
starting to work you're getting a little
honest all these jungle people I didn't
know what was going
on there was that horrid noise that
blurring Matrix phone I had taken a fist
full of red pill it it's so bad the
writing this article is so terrible it's
so terrible I I I don't know if I even
believe this person did it I don't
know but this is
what my recurring thought was I'm dead
and this is Hell forever that's
everybody that has a bad trap it's so
cliche it's such a cliche this is like
anyone who read any of those bad trip
reports and wrote about them and just
took this I was in that room for about
90 minutes but but that feels like lying
because I know I was in that void for
days see this is like a I don't even
know if this happened like I don't even
know if this happened or if this person
just took all these bad like trip
reports there used to be this website I
forget what it was called but it it was
it was a website and people used to
write about their experiences with drugs
don't look for it it doesn't matter um
people will know who are listening to
the show what it was and people would
write about their experiences with DMT
or other drugs and all of these are the
most cliche things to say and it might
that might be the case that they just
happen so frequently to people that they
all describe them the same way I don't I
don't know but this idea that like like
ketamine therapy is going to help all
the people that want it is crazy it's
crazy it's not true there it's there
it's a drug and it might work for you
and listen psychedelic therapies might
be good there's a lot of evidence that
these things are going to help right
military people I'm not discounting all
of this stuff I'm just going always the
only thing I can do is talk about
personal experience all I can do is talk
about the scores of people I know in Los
Angeles on these things and people claim
that they're uh there's benefits but
then I know a lot of these people and it
doesn't seem that beneficial
so then they they contacted him they go
you need more ketamine you should come
back you should come
back
and can anyone get this can I just go in
can anyone go in and get ketamine
therapy do you need a note from your
doctor do you need a note no you don't
need a note no you just I don't even
need a note I could just go in and get
ketamine shot up yeah khole yeah I could
just go do that yeah that's what we're
at uhuh
nice okay sure I mean listen people are
going to get mad at me for this this is
when I told people not to smoke pot in
their 30s it was the most controversial
episode I ever did people were so angry
I said marijuana is for your teenage
years as you get older you should use it
very sparingly and people got so angry
with
me and they they they boiled over into
rage as people often do when I'm right
which I usually am and I feel the same
way about this [__] it's
like are the people that really are they
utilizing it in an appropriate way are
these PE are is
this is this being utilized in an
appropriate way or are a lot of people
going in there with no clue what's going
on and leaving with somehow less of a
clue of what's going on and listen I get
it people are happy and K I mean it is a
therapy
and some people like it but it's a
you're going into a
khaul for
drugs it's what it is you're you're
disconnecting from the world with a
drug now maybe
it maybe it can treat other things and
it might be able
to but it's just fun there's
this it's not like the idea per se is
wrong it's the application of it the
application that anyone can just walk in
a room and do
ketamine uh and then as much as they
want and then follow their own uh plan
seems stupid it seems pretty dumb